hello water welcome to this video
playing the lotus eater frequent
opponent relatively frequent five games
I feel I haven't played them for quite a
while so let's see what we get this line
I have an interesting idea that would be
through Bishop e3 going to try that now
I have more than one interesting idea
that actually veterans is the one I will
go for now Knight f6 now is the normal
option at this one okay I want about
efore here somehow with him having less
control there hmm if this is this is an
idea there's some other drawing Casey
successor is a bit of an earlier
commitment down taking I tell you on the
8th really never leads to anything I
think I'll go before him if he takes e4
I can take a five I think very likely it
will just plain I GF 6 yeah and I'm not
so sure now about this trait and five
that looks kind of unstable check so i
can go Knight f3 now for example to tech
this hard to it's not easy to evaluate
but ok let's do it
ok just like that if it takes a fourth
95 so not afraid about the afraid about
this yeah i was thinking wookie one
trying to put more pressure on you five
again if he takes on 95 regains this and
then you will be somewhat stuck with
this if I've porn and the a goodie
foursquare for my pieces it doesn't have
to be all that dramatic but night a 62
before as an interesting idea yeah and
just as I mentioned it he plays it yeah
hmm that's something that is definitely
on the cards taking hmm doesn't look
good and not see 5s is really a really
really a nuisance here okay let's just
try this maybe if no f4 doesn't really
look good night before I have Bishop c5
was my idea
FYI can take and go Bishop before that
that's not good I think and still if he
takes not chief I so probably probably
still okay for me even though that night
a six I saw too late if I getting rooked
e1b three get some stability I might
have chances to exploit the slightly
loose pawn structure if I have an f5
even though it can never be um it can
never be a big deal okay so he wants to
trade stuff here or it's possible and
I'd see to that we have this kind of
funky trades can I take this okay so he
is gotten the bishop and that deal but
still there are there are weaknesses him
and he is ok him he should be ok maybe
you can just take take only form
you
you
he's a little bit behind a development
that that can be a factor here oh that's
that's that's interesting tries to treat
him I mean okay i can take a five takes
you 45 for for a pawn okay yes God
rookie aid at the end there but it's
still a pawn and I still don't like that
somehow
oh my god you should I should really
calculate something once in a while and
not just play the move what else what am
i what am I expecting for him to play it
oh my god yeah that's pretty sick him
that I didn't think about this move okay
um where do I go rube t3 there's night
to see 50 k e 5 is hanging so and still
possible that this is still quite okay
rook da them for looped it towards the
thing look the age 95 looked it true
with the thing and then it's the Nichols
92 am absolutely hmm that's some way to
take there and then handle this this
removes the city it's pretty awkward
pretty awkward
I bishop f 192 I can actually take if I
take if five rook takes takes I am
taking too long here okay let's let's
play it 92 95 night f1 King f1 loop t2i
doesn't doesn't really react together
all time morning take now is still 22
what was my idea down no idea kind of
stupid
okay can with this and that my house
stupid can you play really that was
suppose extremely stupid play by me
overlooking what we're looking at let's
stuff with them Bishop a five extremely
bad idea this is just trying to keep it
simple i guess but because of the Torah
I heard right kind of pointless draw our
third game drum and I probably can we
don't time it's just totally pointless
and Bishop a fire what did i do thou
shalt not sure he I mean maybe this is
maybe this is very this is somewhat
equality I felt I have a little bit of
something here but maybe not so with
this interesting idea is this yeah now I
should just take it I can just take here
was but um and it didn't feel like
enough to me that was the thing this
locate check yeah he's got the bishop
pair that's not an easy we know anything
they thought I just did just keep the
position and then it's got this one
which is really awkward yeah and yet
it's very difficult to to hold at least
with this time situation and King e7 is
strong I'm not quite sure what I was
thinking there with bishop f1 that was
just a bad decision the engine wants to
go here and claims equal still
yeah let's let's check it here and then
g4 okay this is a very concrete yeah
yeah okay now I get to know I'm into
into deep trouble I basically got got
saved by them but saved by the by the
time situation because he he can play
for Whitney with luke t 6 i'm not sure
that this is a successful tribe but okay
after this it's definitely just equal
yeah i was a bad game a bad game okay
thanks for watching